>> BEFORE WE EAT, I WANT TO SAY
A FEW WORDS.
>> MAKE IT QUICK, DAD.
I'M STARVING.
>> I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
BEING HERE.
NOT JUST THE IMMEDIATE FAMILY.
I'M TALKING ABOUT ALL THE
COUSINS AND KIDS AND EVERYBODY.
>> THAT'S HOW IT SHOULD BE.
>> I KNOW EVERYBODY IS BUSY WITH
THEIR LIVES.
THEIR OWN THINGS THEY HAVE TO DO
BUT IT MEANS SO MUCH THAT YOU'RE
HERE IN OUR HOME FOR THE
HOLIDAYS.
>> THAT GOES FOR BOTH OF US.
>> MY SISTER'S HOUSE --
>> I HAVE TO PAY FOR ALL THIS
FOOD?
HELL NO.
>> AS I HAVE ALWAYS SAID, THIS
HOUSE IS HAPPIER WHEN IT'S IF
YOU HAVE.
>> GET OUT OF THE BATHROOM!
>> SO YOU'VE BEEN SUCH GRACIOUS
HOSTS.
I HOPE I HAVEN'T BEEN A
NUISANCE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
WE LOVE HAVING YOU HERE.
>> AND OF COURSE, THIS IS OUR
FIRST CHRISTMAS WITH OUR SOON TO
BE SON-IN-LAW MATTHEW.
WHEN YOU TWO GOT ENGAGED, ALL OF
US WERE SMILING FROM EAR TO EAR.
>> WHY CANNOT I MARRY HIM?
BECAUSE HE'S WHITE?
>> YES.
>> WELCOME TO THE FAMILY,
MATTHEW.
>> YOU GUYS ARE BEING SO RACIST.
>> DAMN RIGHT WE ARE.
>> NO OFFENSE.
>> NONE TAKEN.
>> I'M JUST EMBARRASSED WE HAVE
TO PUT YOU TWO ON THE AIR
MATTRESS.
>> FOR THE LAST TIME, IT'S FINE.
>> IT'S ACTUALLY SUPER
COMFORTABLE.
>> AND THEN THERE IS BRIAN.
BACK FROM COLLEGE.
IT SURE IS GREAT TO HAVE MY BOY
BACK HOME FOR A FEW WEEKS.
>> IT FEELS GOOD TO BE HOME,
DAD.
>> I AM PUSHING IT.
>> NO.
NO.
>> GET YOUR USELESS BLACK ASS
OUT OF HERE.
SON, GET BACK IN HERE.
>> WELL, I JUST WANT TO SAY AS
YOU GET OLDER, IT ALL GOES THAT
MUCH QUICKER.
WE SHOULD ALL CHERISH THIS TIME
WE ALL SPEND TOGETHER AT
CHRISTMAS.
>> I KNOW I WILL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I COULD GO ON.
BUT I KNOW BETTER THAN TO LET A
MEAL MY WIFE SPENT SO MUCH TIME
COOKING GO COLD.
>> OH, STOP.
I JUST THREW IT TOGETHER.
NO, NO, NO!
>> ANYWAY, THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE.
AND I REALLY MEAN THAT.
I KNOW IT MIGHT BE A LITTLE
CROWDED --
>> THIS ROOM IS OFF LIMITS.
>> GET OFF ME!
>> AND WE MIGHT EVEN GET ON EACH
OTHER'S NERVES.
>> WHATEVER IT IS, NO!
>> THIS IS GOING TO MAKE THE
MEMORIES LAST A LIFETIME.
>> GRANDPA!
LOCK THE DOOR!
>> CHRISTMAS IS ABOUT FAMILY.
AND I AM BLESSED TO SPEND IT
WITH MINE.
CHEERS!
>> CHEERS!
>> THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL, DAD.
>> WELL THAT, SON.
>> THAT WAS GREAT, DAD.